welcome to my model lifestyle channel my
name is Daniel Moritz and in this video
I'm gonna talk about how to get a good
model portfolio you have not subscribed
yet please subscribe so you can see some
new and upcoming videos so let's get
into this
all right guys so what is a model
portfolio well a model portfolio is
basically your best features as you can
serve to the client so that they can be
key for jobs that's basically it
but let's get into this a little bit
more you might get a book like this
isn't my model folio I'm from South
Africa and my mother agency is boss
models now this is their book and what
you do is you take one of these books
you go to the casting and so you show it
to the client and a client look through
your book and they see what kind of
model you are now I'm a more a
commercial type of model which is more
smiling more natural it's getting the
photo and they go through these pictures
and they see basically the experience
that you have asked a lot and they book
you based on your portfolio but also how
you appear to them even the castings
before how you for their clubs so the
model portfolio is very very important
to get better your mom portfolio is
there chances you have right so how do
you get a model portfolio well if you're
a beginner number one you have to do it
as many test shoots as you possibly can
the quicker you get a better portfolio
set up together the better chances you
have to get good modeling jobs right now
how do you get set shoes well your
agency can probably help you with that
they have the contact stages set up to
test you and that's how you start to get
pictures now the pictures that you have
to focus on first is you have to get at
least a good headshot
it's very very important then you also
need some picture that shows off your
body then you can bring in different
styles you can bring in the business
kind of law suit climate clothes and you
can bring it sport clothes varieties key
you have to give different angles as
well look in the mirror and see which
sides of your face looks the best is it
the left he's in the right then which
side the smiles you know from the camera
straight from the camera to the left or
the right
it's a look in practice we'll see you
front you have different Franz Brown and
look at the mirror practice a little bit
and see what is really good so that when
you do the test shoots you can give it a
variety of expressions variety of poses
and a variety of angles that you do in
front of the camera all right say do the
test shoot so after you've done a couple
accessory you would be able to go to
some capsules and hopefully you can do
some jobs so at the beginning you need
to do a lot of techniques right then
actually start getting jobs you'll start
to get more and more features but
getting your pictures will never stop
this is something that he will
continually do - as a model even if
you're experienced it doesn't matter you
need to continually update your book so
that it corresponds with your age and
also with your experience alright guys
so now you know how to get a good model
portfolio thank you for checking the
video please subscribe if you liked the
video and also if you want to know more
about modeling well I have added my
model course in the description where I
give you all my best tips that I have
learned over the last 10 years of being
a male model see you in the next video
[Music]